do a thoughtful advice go ahead do you
want a dark one our relationship you
made dark one
I'm hopeful advice with Bobby while I
look at age three hey everyone I need a
voice filter sobbing go ahead hey
everyone my name is Matt and I'm 25 from
Ontario Canada over the past 10 years
I've been dealing with severe depression
anxiety this caused me to be withdrawn
and secluded even when I would like to
go out and be active at one point it was
so bad that I ended up losing a great
job and tell him telecommunications
industry as well as my relationship with
my single father because I simply
couldn't find the motivation to even
wake up and go to work I ended up
becoming homeless for a short time
before being approved for government
assistance since then I found a home and
after getting my father to one of the
therapy sessions I've been attending he
seemed to start to understand why I am
the way I am even though everything has
seemed to have gotten better on the
outside looking in I can tell you today
I feel worse than when I was homeless
yeah every day seems to be worse than
the last one I can't seem to shake the
feeling off I have no motivation I have
no sex drive
I have no creativity I have no real
hunger for anything this feeling has
caused me to attempt to commit suicide
about a month ago and I was wondering if
any of you have dealt with similar
feelings before what have you done to
escape them I thought I'm looking for a
girlfriend but I also don't want anyone
to have do this right the relationship
one a cat star again what do you think I
can do to help move on and escape these
feelings thanks for taking the time to
read mat I think there's something else
going on I think did he say he does
drugs did he say there are no drugs I
feel like there's I mean I'm I don't
know it does it literally reminds me of
the introduction to Eckhart Tolle's
the power of now you know he was a guy
who had no lust for life he was living
in a one-bedroom I think living in
Canada as well it was cold he was
sitting on a mattress and he's like yeah
I'm done with life right and then he had
a spiritual awakening in the middle of
the night and his life changed and he
created the philosophy of I mean living
at the moment is
probably in the Sermon on the mountain
and whatnot but he that was his thing I
think that reading that introduction and
reading that book would help this person
individual can I decide it why got a
sigh you got a side because you know it
you know you saw but let me just let me
just kind of just give me a second okay
you're flexing I don't know why but
here's the place let me say what I want
to say okay is the whole philosophy even
in 12-step groups they say one day at a
time right but that's not what they mean
what they mean is live in the moment
okay because most people walk around
they live in the past and in the future
what's gonna happen in future and they
worry about what happened in the past
right and the thing is is that I used to
have a sponsor named Dan right when I
was in 17 years old and used to arm step
in front of me right and go and clap now
here here here anyone get you out of
your head yeah right right here now no
right I used to get me out of my thing
you know a lot of the torment 99% of my
tournament is in my mind of course right
yes I'm stuck in my head and I'm
thinking about everything but being here
right now in this present moment and you
you Bach and you sigh baby okay but but
what I'm saying is is that Lex this
you've lacked I just look I think that
if you're getting everything that you
just said applies to most of the
population but having been somebody who
has been so deeply depressed and haven't
attempted to take her own life that
doesn't quite apply because I think that
here's a person who is so just bereft of
like every ounce of everything in his
life I don't I think that he is
explaining and describing somebody who
is truly and chemically depressed and
you can be the way I always used to feel
was you could
puts around me with everybody that I
love on the sunniest day of the year
in Disneyland and if I'm feeling that
pit of depression there's no getting me
out of that and it's just that a
chemical imbalance that's just keeping
me down there irrationally well there's
there's there's different levels to
approaching depression like especially
one that severe right first of all the
guy he has a desire to get better that's
the yeah the person right poor thing
he recognizes I'm sick there's no joy in
my life and I want to get better so
that's important he still has hope Bobby
is [ __ ] snooze I know I'm Lissa this
is how I listen you're in deep yeah here
should we wrap it up wrap it up there's
no no no that's what so just let me just
say something before I'm not gonna say
anything about this situation okay yeah
I heard everything you said I'm hearing
everything you said but for me to not
you know interrupt and really take in
what you're saying I had to close my
eyes and I pretend that I'm sleeping but
don't take that an offense okay because
I've been speaking mostly to you because
we've been having a direct but when
you're nodding off don't do it but then
if I if I if I'm like look at your eye
if I'm like this and I won't be
listening yeah close your eyes so he's
got a desire to get better that's first
most important that's that's good he's
still got the spark in him okay the
thing is like when you're that depressed
and you're that you have that you're
that hopeless you you need to force
yourself to do things
mm-hmm like he's it's so easy to just
get stuck in bed and be like I feel like
[ __ ] and there's no [ __ ] reason for
me to get out of bed by the other hand
ended his mind he knows that he is
depressed and he hates that he doesn't
want to get it so what do you need to do
you know what you need to do you need to
go out of bed you know go for to apply
for a job you need to go do your laundry
or whatever it is you have to force
yourself to do it because you know
that's what you need to do even though
you don't want to do it yeah you have to
fake it you have to fake it and fake it
and fake it that's true get your [ __ ]
together but just by sheer force of will
yeah I think that you do there is an
element you have to sort of
white-knuckle yourself out of that and
I had a really good therapist and I was
in my teens and we used to do weekly
contracts of things that I would force
myself to do and I think that really
really helped I mean even things like
something as simple as working out or
even raising your you know your
endorphins just a little to battle and
you went and you won that day yeah
and I'm somebody who like lives with
extreme anxiety I don't think there's a
minute in my life we're like my palms
aren't like sweaty looking you see or
like you know I'm trying to like I
always feel like I'm trying to I feel
like I have to get out of a situation
that's always what my body feels like
like even if it's something really
Pleasant like I feel like I have to flee
and then with someone who's that
clinically depressed yeah chemically
depressed you need you need help you
need professional help yeah and you need
drugs drugs are there for people who
they're really effective and and it
helps people who really need it
there's two types of people who are
depressed there's people who are like
circumstantially depressed and there's a
couple things in their life that bothers
them things about themselves that they
want to approve and if you've tried all
that stuff because most people in my
opinion don't go through the effort of
actually confronting all those things
they don't like about themselves to get
out of that rut because it's easy it's
it's much easier not to but if you've
gone through the effort of doing all
that stuff and you still are faking it
and you're still depressed then that's
when you do drugs yeah I agree but that
car sold also a really great book the
power of now all right know a simple
thing like that you never know what's
gonna spark that one Japanese murder I
want to say Komori
oh yeah shut-ins yeah he cook on Maury I
um that's my that is my that's how I
feel what heaven would be like hmm being
a shut-in yes I don't want you think I
want to communicate with people I'm a
depressed guy myself you know I did
drugs like you know I you know I did
everything I could to fill that hole
inside me I [ __ ] hate it might one of
my biggest fantasies is to shoot heroin
in a trailer in the desert and die I
mean that's what I want to do right but
you know I have parents and my brother
and people around me that love me and
rely on me and I have to try you know I
have to try to be a part of you know so
I get I mean i i'm probably not
clinically depressed like this person
that just emailed but you know i get you
know what he's saying you know so you
know i you think I want to read power on
that you think I want to read self-help
books you think I want to go to a
meeting you think I want to do any of
the things that I do to get out of you
know but I don't but I have to but
you're so right it might you might find
something to like sparks you think you
know what and twice about that but the
part is being open like okay grab the
book read it you have to be willing and
desperate to find yeah to find your
answer I fear not snow or die or die I
feel like the fact that he even wrote
this message and got for us to answer it
yeah it's a really bigger company was
able to express it eloquently yeah when
I am when I'm in that depressed mode I
feel like I would never even bring
myself to write that message and send it
so that's true
[Music]